The Marvel Cinematic Universe isn't done with
the Avengers — but that doesn't mean that
fans should expect more of the same.
Speaking with MTV News at San Diego Comic-Con
2019, studio boss Kevin Feige revealed that
Mighty Marvel indeed has plans for its flagship
superhero team moving forward — but that
said team will look quite a bit different
from what we're used to.
This shouldn't come as too big of a shock,
because in terms of brand recognition, the
Avengers name is without equal in the world
of mainstream film.
Each of the four films that have been released
so far with that word in the title have grossed
over a billion dollars at the worldwide box
office.
The Infinity Saga-culminating Avengers: Endgame
even became the all-time box office champion,
surpassing the decade-old record previously
held by James Cameron's Avatar.
"Magnificent!
Magnificent!
MAGNIFICENT!"
According to Feige, a new iteration of the
Avengers is on the horizon — but it's not
likely to feature many, if any, revamped versions
of heroes we're familiar with.
The King Geek was asked point-blank by MTV
News if he and the rest of the Marvel Studios
brain trust know what the next Avengers team
will look like, and he replied, "Yes."
After a lengthy pause, Feige continued,
"It will be a very different team than what
we've seen before, that's what Endgame was
all about.
It will be a very different incarnation of
the team, with some people you've already
met, and some people you haven't met yet."
Whatever form this team eventually takes,
it seems safe to say that we won't see another
proper Avengers film for quite some time,
considering that the entirety of Marvel's
Phase 4 slate was announced during the studio's
rapturously received Comic-Con panel — and
there was nary a giant team-up flick to be
found.
There may be a few clues, however, hidden
in the details we know so far about Phase
4 and beyond.
First, it's been revealed that two prominent
characters will be getting their introductions
by way of standalone solo flicks in the coming
years — one during Phase 4, and one during
Phase 5.
February 12th, 2021, will see the release
of Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings,
which will introduce audiences worldwide to
the legendary Master of Kung Fu — along
with… drumroll please! … the actual Mandarin!
"You want something?
Take it!
Although, the guns are all fake because the
w***ers wouldn't trust me with the real ones."
"What?"
We said the actual Mandarin!
Get outta here, Trevor!
Anyway…
Marvel hopes that the flick — with its mostly
Asian cast and behind-the-camera talent — will
be the kind of paradigm-shifting event that
2018's Black Panther proved to be, and if
this works out like we all know it probably
will, the character would be a fine inclusion
in team-up films in the future.
In the comics, Shang-Chi — although he has
no superpowers for most of his heroic career
— is among the finest unarmed combatants
in existence, more than capable of going toe-to-toe
with superpowered opponents.
Phase 5 will bring us the solo vehicle for
that deadly, smack-talking half human-half
vampire Blade, who was portrayed by Wesley
Snipes in the successful film trilogy of the
late '90s and early 2000s.
In the MCU, the "daywalker" will be played
by two-time Oscar winner Mahershala Ali, and
it seems unlikely that Marvel would cast an
actor of that caliber without having some
pretty big plans for the future.
Save for those two additions to some potential
super squad… well, who knows?
Feige suggested to MTV News that, though there
may never be another culmination of a decade-long
arc like Endgame, that doesn't mean that the
future of the MCU won't play host to some
thrilling events.
He elaborated:
"That's what I love about the Marvel comic
method of storytelling.
I love things that build up, they build to
a crescendo, they all get together, they separate,
they change.
And now that we get to do that, not just in
movies but on these mega-event series on Disney+,
it's just invigorated all of us at Marvel
Studios to keep going."
Feige and company certainly haven't steered
us wrong so far, and like you, we can't wait
to see what they have in store for us in the
years ahead.
It'll be interesting to see whether Marvel
can make household names out of some relatively
lesser-known characters yet again — which
is almost certainly the plan, and we wouldn't
bet against them.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.